- Well, you're gonna
do some talking.
- Hello.
- I'm Mark Gagliardi.
- And today,
we're gonna talk about...
- Oh, is this really
that part of the thing?
- Yep.
- Yeah, now you're woken up.
Here he comes.
- This is how television works,
bitches.
- Ready?
- Which camera?
- Action.
- Hi, I'm Mark Gagliardi.
[glass crashes]
Today we're gonna talk about
Bass Reeves.
- [laughs]
- Bass Reeves is born
as a slave.
One night,
Bass Reeves and his master
get in an argument
over a poker game.
Bass Reeves...
punches his owner
in the face.
And Bass Reaves
thinks to himself,
Oh, [bleep], you guys,
I just coldcocked my boss.
Listen, let's be honest,
my owner.
This is probably not
gonna be good for me.
So, Bass Reeves hightails it
to the Indian Territories
of Oklahoma.
So, Bass Reeves
winds up living among
the Seminole Nation,
learning the language of all
of these indigenous peoples.
And trained in the ways
of Native American
tracking and hunting.
- Hmm, awesome.
- Ah, I appreciate you,
Derek.
I love you.
- I love you.
- You're my--listen, I'm--
We're gonna make a baby.
- Um...
[both laugh]
- I may be aimed down at the
ground for the whole of this,
but don't worry about that.
In 1875 the U.S. is changing.
Taming the Wild West
and all that kinda [bleep].
U.S. Marshal James Fagan knew
that this was dangerous work.
He needed the guy that
full on dances with wolvesed
in that area.
- [laughs]
- So, Fagan goes to Reeves.
Hey, I have 75,000 square miles
to cover
to bring bad guys to justice.
And Bass Reeves said,
Listen, I'm ambidextrous,
I can shoot a gun
with both hands.
I'm 6'2" and 390 pounds.
I'm gonna be the guy
that keeps you safe.
The only thing I can say
to you is...
I'm gonna tape a--take a nap.
[bleep] you.
- ♪ There he goes
on the floor ♪
- Derek?
- Mm-hmm?
- Take my hand.
- Good night, then.
- Night.
So...
So, Bass Reeves is working
as a U.S. Marshal,
picking up bad guys.
So, one of the bad guy things
that he does is,
he dresses himself up
as an old beggar
at the homestead of
a couple of bad guys' mother.
He says,
I'm just a poor old beggar.
I just need a place to stay
for the night.
So she gives Bass Reeves
a place to spend the night.
As soon as the two outlaws
fell asleep,
Bass Reeves
pulled down his shawl,
grabs his six shooter.
He says,
The Bass w--hold on.
I'm gonna corner
their dumb asses
while they're sleeping.
I'll sleep you--
I will sleep clack you
into my handcuffs, bitches!
And I'm gonna grag you...
I'm gonna grag you--hold on.
I'm gonna drag your asses
in jail
where I gathered up
all the criminals.
- That's pretty badass.
- Listen, mother[bleep],
I'll tell you this whole story,
hold on.
This is how big a badass
Bass Reeves is.
The Brunter Brothers,
another group of outlaws,
ambushed him at gunpoint.
Bass Reeves kept his cool,
turned to the first
Brunter Brother and said,
I'm sorry, do you know what
the date is today?
And as that brother was
trying to figure out
the date for the day,
Bass Reeves shoots
the first two brothers.
And then coldcocked
the other brother
and carried them back
to the court at Fort Lewis.
And they're like,
You know what?
[bleep] you,
Bass Reeves!
[bleep] you and your knowing
what's right and wrong!
[bleep] you, Honest...
Honest Jack Reeves!
[bleep] you,
Bass Reeves,
and your wanting to give
the honesty to the people!
- Mark.
- I love you.
- [laughing]
I'ma kiss you on your lips.
Derek Waters.
- No.
- I'ma kiss you on your lips.
- I just wanna
hold your face.
- Will you finish
the story if I do this?
- I promise
I will.
- Promise?
- I'm--
- No slapping.
- I'm not gonna slap you,
Derek.
- What're you
gonna do?
- Derek?
[sighs]
- That was
very nice.
- I'm gonna
take a nap now.
- Nope. You promised,
if you could touch my face...
- I'll touch your face.
- You were gonna finish
the [bleep] story.
- I'ma finish it, hold on.
So, uh, one night,
Bass Reeves is chasing after
Jim Webb.
He'd killed a ton of dudes,
and Bass Reeves--
pew, pew, pew--
shot down this dude.
And this guy is laying there,
on the ground,
looks up at Bass Reeves,
and he says,
Bass, this bullet
that is designed for you...
Nah, man.
I want this bullet
to be designed
for people that [bleep] you up.
That guy, Jim Webb,
gave that gun to Bass Reeves
because he respects him.
Derek.
- Shh.
Tell the story.
- I love you.
- Bass Reeves threw
more men in jail
than any other Marshal
in U.S. history,
3,000 men.
And when he died,
his funeral was attended
by hundreds of people.
White...
Black...
Native American...
and whatever the other thing
was that they had.
And they all went
to pay their respects to this,
the most important man,
of the wild frontier.
You know what?
Reeves was the inspiration...
for the Lone Ranger.
- How come more people
don't know that Bass Reeves
is who inspired
the Lone Ranger?
- Because he's black.
- That's sad.
- Yeah.
- Well, we're
changing history now.